[Music]
I'm gonna be talking about a problem
where the problem is one instance of
something that's a little more general
and I'll also be talking about in our
package for a particular solution
approach but at the end of the talk I
will mention other packages with
complimentary approaches and sort of
higher level messages about how this
problem although we're thinking about
selections specifically if we're
thinking about data science at a high
level the problem generalizes to using
the same data for multiple for at
different points of the data science
pipeline so if we're using the same data
to both decide what questions to ask and
then answer those questions that would
be an example of the type of problem
that I'm talking about so this is work
which is or this talk will be based on
work that I have with a number of
co-authors and a lot of other work that
I was you know I'm talking about their
work as well because because of the sort
of general audience here I wanted to
talk about this whole area and not just
my specific research in this area so
these are some of my co-authors and this
is an area that still got active
research happening in it with with
papers being published and the R package
is still under like development and
being updated so in I'm not going to
reinvent calculating integrals but I'm
also going to try to not reinvent
regression so I'm gonna instead call
regression artificial intelligence and
say it's been around since you know the
18th century or the 19th century the
prototypical problem that I'll talk
about in this talk will be about
regression modeling but the higher-level
ideas about answering questions using
the same data that you've used to decide
what questions to ask those those
higher-level ideas are there whether
you're thinking about regression or
something else
so regression as a method for predicting
some outcome variable using other
prediction variables has been around for
centuries
but but not it it hasn't been around for
that long the methods to do inference
for regression so maybe one century so
two centuries over here one century over
here and this is a sort of typical thing
that we see in data science that we
often come up with ways to model data
and predict using these models and stuff
before we figure out how to analyze
whether we can trust those ways of
predicting things so in early 20th
century william sealy gosset also known
as student and fisher had a lot of
correspondence with each other where
they were working out how to calculate
things like hypothesis tests and
intervals for the coefficients and a
regression model this is this is a
excerpt from a paper published by
Fischer which is at the at the time
people were using chi-squared tests for
goodness of fit for to check if the
modeling assumption and the data that
they had were kind of consistent with
each other and it turned out that when
people are doing these calculations they
weren't calculating the degrees of
freedom for that test correctly and so
Fisher figured out the correct way to
find out what the degrees of freedom
were and he's talking about that here
and he's it's kind of interesting he's
saying that the values of P have been
exaggerated is to be feared that in many
cases wrong conclusions have been drawn
from the values of P obtained so if
you're familiar with kind of the current
present-day debates in statistical
methods about using p-values and whether
or not there's any problems with using
p-values those those questions have been
around since the very beginning of
hypothesis testing in fact before people
even knew how to do hypothesis test
regression coefficients so this is a
historical kind of background of the
type of problem that I'm going to talk
about and I'll be a little specific and
show some mathematical detail before
going into some examples of the R
package but here's a one slide
hypothesis test review just to say very
concretely what what I'm the specific
example I'm talking about today will be
so we're looking at a regression model
which is we know is a very sophisticated
high dimensional artificial intelligence
and we're going to think about two
different types of tests hypothesis
tests that we could do for the
parameters in such a model so we could
test coefficients in this model we could
for example check the null hypothesis
that a given coefficient is zero and we
designed these tests with the first goal
in mind of controlling type one error
and the type 1 error is the probability
assuming that null hypothesis is true
that we reject it so that would be it or
that's the probability of the type 1
error rejecting the null hypothesis when
it's true as a type 1 error and we want
the probability of that happening to be
less than some predetermined
significance level and we usually
construct tests this way by forming a
test statistic for this coefficient and
we have some we can compute to the
p-value for this test by looking at the
observed value of the test statistic and
then looking at the probability under
the null that we would see something at
least as extreme so this is this is
basically the machinery that Fisher was
writing about in 1922 and we know how to
do this using for example the T
distribution for regression coefficients
I won't go into as much detail about
goodness of fit tests so I won't I won't
write down mathematical details for
those but the idea for those tests are
the the null hypothesis is that the
modeling assumption you've made for
example the modeling assumption of this
linear model
with certain distributional assumptions
about the errors that that modeling
assumption fits the data so that would
be the null hypothesis so for a goodness
of fit test rejecting the null
hypothesis would mean that the model
does not fit the data so we some of the
modeling assumptions might have been
wrong and we should really think about a
different type of model so these are the
two types of tests that I want to think
about but again like even if you're a
Bayesian you don't do these these
specific types of methods you can still
think about what types of properties you
want your inference tools to have and
the types of problems that I'm going to
illustrate with these methods are
problems that you should still be
worried about even if you're a Bayesian
and you're not using p-values as your
primary methodology okay so this is the
type of problem we're gonna think about
and to look at an example let's consider
an example where the null hypothesis
actually is true and our model is very
simple we just have one predictor
variable so here I've generated data
where the outcome variable and the
predictor variable are both just
independent normal random variables so
there's no the slope is actually zero
that null hypothesis is true and I fit a
linear model using my trusty LM function
in R and I can look at the p-value for
the test for the predictor variable and
it's 0.6 so that p-value being larger
than 0.05
I would not reject the null hypothesis
and the point of the the frequentist
guarantee that we're hoping to have with
our null hypothesis testing method is
that if we were to repeat this many
times for example a thousand times that
we would not reject the null hypothesis
too often and indeed we can check if we
repeat this a thousand times we only end
up rejecting the null hypothesis 60 out
of what those 1,000 times and if we
chose a different significance level
instead of 5% if we
one percent then we would want to reject
the null hypothesis only about one
percent of the time so on this slide
everything is fine and good this is how
things should work this is how the test
was designed to work so this is great
now let's see let's think about how this
could become a little more complicated
so on the previous slide I just had one
predictor variable one outcome variable
you look at real data sets and you
usually don't find that level of
simplicity usually find many predictor
variables and you might want to choose
from among a candidate set of many
predictor variables a subset so that you
can have a simple linear model that
doesn't have too many coefficients in it
there are various reasons you might want
to do that for example you might not
have that many observations and you
couldn't even do least squares
regression if you have more predictors
and observations so you would like to
select a small subset of predictors so
you have more observations than
predictors and you can do least squares
regression that would be one reason you
would like to do this other reasons are
you just don't know which predictors you
should put in the model at all you have
no sort of prior knowledge about which
things would be predictive of why you
want to just use the data to pick which
predictors to put in the model there are
a number of methods algorithms for doing
this automatically for us so for about a
half century people have known about and
used forward stepwise as one possible
algorithm and what that does is it
starts with an empty model and adds one
predictor at a time choosing from the
set of candidate predictors the one
that's most correlated with the outcome
a little more recently there are some
other methods other algorithms that
people have proposed including the lasso
by tips Ronnie which minimizes the
squared error like least squares does
but it then penalize --is the
coefficients so this penalty term means
that when you minimize this you choose
coefficients to minimize this you're
trying to have small prediction error
we are trying to do it at a low cost in
the size of the coefficients and this
algorithm tends to have nice properties
for example it usually gives you a
sparse solution meaning that the the
vector beta will have few entries that
are not 0 so we can think of it as a
method for selecting a subset of
predictors those predictors which have
coefficients which are not 0 we use this
this penalty parameter here of lambda to
determine how much penalisation we want
to do on the coefficients if lambda is
larger then we end up shrinking the
coefficients towards zero for large
enough lambda the minimizer would just
be the zero vector
if we let lambda become smaller then
we're penalizing the coefficients less
and we can get closer to something like
the least squares solution if that is
defined okay so these are two types of
algorithms we might think about for
choosing predictor variables in a
regression model let's see an example of
one of these algorithms in action on a
particular data set just to illustrate
so in this data set this is the candy
ranking data set from the 538 package
there's a number of variables which are
attributes of different candy like
doesn't have chocolate
how much sugar does it have stuff like
that and there's also a variable which
is we can think of as a measurement of
how popular that candy is so let's build
a model to predict how popular some
candies are based on their attributes
but we don't know a priori which
attributes should be predictive of
popularity so let's let B let some
algorithm choose them for us the the
other attributes in here are like does
the candy have caramel in it is it does
it have new gat is it a hard candy or a
bar so there's like 11 I think predictor
variables in this data set and it can be
tough to think about the meaning of a
coefficient in a regression model with
11 variables in it so let's try to let
this algorithm pick a regression model
with hopefully fewer predictor variables
in it so we have a simpler model to
think about
so let's run forward stepwise regression
so we use the step function in R to do
that and what we find is that it picks
these four predictor variables it says
that Candy's having chocolate being a
hard candy or a bar and then the price
are the variables which are predictive
of the popularity and then we've got in
this column the p-values for these
coefficients so it looks like basically
the the bar one is the only one which is
not significant at the 5% level and
otherwise they're all significant so the
this these results look pretty nice and
we're looking at this candy data set
just because it's kind of simple and
it's easy to understand but you could
imagine doing something like this in
some other setting like healthcare
you're doing something like a gene on
genome-wide Association study where
you've picked which genes are predictive
of some healthcare outcome something
like that and you've got these
inferences and you're ready to publish
these results right we've got a model
which predicts the outcome we've got our
p-values for the predictors in this
model and should we then go and and
publish this is the next question so
there's a there is a problem with this
somewhere and the problem is on the
previous slide I had actually replaced
the outcome variable with just pure
noise it wasn't the popularity of the
candy it was just pure noise so the
model managed to the algorithm managed
to find variables which could predict
pure noise and the tests then told us
that those variables were significant so
that's that's the problem this is an
illustration of the the problem that
we're gonna try to address in this talk
and the problem is selection bias even
though the outcome variable was just
noise by looking for correlations with
many potential predictor variables and
then finding the ones that had the
highest correlation we ended up with
values of predictor variables which
seemed significantly correlated with the
outcome even though we knew that the
outcome here wasn't really correlated
with them so it's that selection that
search among many possible candidates
which makes it so that the hypothesis
test method isn't valid anymore so the
Fisher developed the hypothesis test
method in a setting where people didn't
have these algorithms for picking
variables automatically they instead had
only the predictor variables that they
wanted in their data set they had to
probably collect the data themselves so
those hypothesis testing methods are
implicitly assuming that the hypothesis
you want to test was chosen without
looking at the data you you collected
that variable and you knew you are going
to test that variable that kind of
classical methodology it's very rare to
be in that sort of scenario now when
people have really large data sets and
they are not using one specific model
that they chose before looking at the
data they're usually using the data to
pick the model so this means we're kind
of in trouble if we want to use things
like confidence intervals and hypothesis
tests if we use this classic methodology
which can give us really misleading
looking results when we've combined it
with model selection so here's another
example to illustrate this selection
effect in this example I'm looking at
the largest out of five null effects so
I generate five random normals that have
mean zero and I look at the largest out
of the five if I repeat that many times
and I look at the distribution of the
largest out of those five things then we
can see that that distribution does not
match the standard normal distribution
so if we're doing something like
selecting the the most predictive
looking effect out of a subset of say
five then we can't use the standard
normal distribution to test the
significance of that effect if we did so
our type 1 error rate at a 5 percent
significance level would be about 25
percent so that's that's bad that means
the test statistic method that we want
to use does not control the the type 1
error which was our main goal for using
it so this problem both the previous
example in this example are comes under
many various different names you may
have heard like the winners curse or
overfitting but the one that's most
relevant to the examples I'm talking
about here is selection bias another
example of this kind of unrelated a
different version of regression related
to one of the previous talks we heard
about some auto regressive processes
earlier today in this one we can think
about time series data where the model
that we're going to choose is the order
of an auto regressive process
so I've plotted here two example auto
regressive processes the the top one is
at a r1 and the bottom one is an a r2
and if you're in the type of setting
where you think that your time series
data has this Auto regressive
correlation structure to it and you have
to select the order of how of the auto
regressive process you can use the data
to select the order using some type of
algorithm that will find the order that
has the best information criteria like
an AIC or something like that and that's
what I'm going to do over here and the
simulation results I'm about to explain
so I'm going to look at some auto
regressive processes use the data with
an information criteria like AIC to pick
the order and then I'm going to do a
goodness-of-fit test so this is our
other type of hypothesis
we're thinking about for the for the
coefficients test we saw that the the
method is biased in a way that makes us
think things are more significant than
they really are so let's see what what
selection bias can do for
goodness-of-fit tests there's a type of
test we would do in this scenario called
a lung box test so I'm gonna do hey I
see to pick the order of the regression
model and then the lung box test to see
if that if that model has fits the data
so in the top density plot here you can
see the blue line is the null
distribution of the test statistic and
the shaded area is the density of the
test statistic over many simulations so
the fact that the shaded area matches
the blue line is good in this top panel
because in this top panel this is the
this is when the information criteria
selects the correct order so we're doing
a goodness of fit test we want to see if
this model fits the data and this is the
case where the model does fit the data
so we want to the goodness of fit test
to match its null distribution and it
does great the problem is in this bottom
part this is when the information
criteria selects the wrong order so this
is when the MA we have the wrong model
in this case we want the goodness of fit
test to actually reject the null
hypothesis we would like to see this
shaded region be larger than the blue
density curve we want to see values of
this test statistic which are large
because the null hypothesis is false
instead what we see is that the test
statistic still matches the null
distribution even though the null
distribution is false so what this is
telling us is that exactly when we
select the wrong model our test can't
tell us that we selected the wrong model
the reason for this is again because
this goodness of fit test was designed
under the assumption that
the model would be chosen without using
the data so if we use the model or yeah
if we use the data to choose the model
and then do the test we're breaking that
test so the goodness of fit test can't
tell us that the model doesn't fit
so to summarize these these examples if
we're thinking about significance of
predictors then when we do model
selection our standard inference methods
are going to be anti conservative
they're going to tell us yes those
predictors are significant this makes
sense because our model selection
algorithms are usually looking for which
predictors seem most predictive and then
our test statistic is kind of checking
how predictive is this predictor
similarly for goodness of fit tests we
have this selection bias but it goes in
the opposite direction instead of being
anti conservative it makes goodness of
fit tests conservative and this also
makes sense because the goodness of fit
test is asking if the model fits the
data and if we use the data to pick the
model then we're finding the model that
fits the data best so then when we check
for goodness of fit the test is just
going to tell us yes it fits even when
we pick the wrong model okay so this
might seem just kind of like a obscure
statistical mathematical theoretical
concern is it really important I would
say yes I think this is one of the
important factors behind a pretty
important and impactful problem which is
often referred to as a reproducibility
crisis and this is a quote this is a
passage from a paper in the open science
collaboration called estimating the
reproducibility of psychological science
where they tried to replicate a hundred
different studies in three psychology
journals and what they found was when
they tried to replicate the findings of
these studies only about 40% of the
effects were rated to have replicated
the original result
so this is this is telling us you know
the point of this paper is that there is
something like a replication a
reproducibility crisis where we have
results being published in peer-reviewed
journals and when people try to
replicate those results they can't they
they don't get the same result so that's
a problem we're using statistical
methods because we're hoping that these
statistical methods will only give us
publishable effects that are
reproducible and then when people try to
reproduce them they're not able to to do
so so I think that this selection bias
could be one of the main reasons why
this is happening people are using their
data set to pick which effects to test
and then they find the tests that the
effects that look significant and they
publish them just like in our candy
example but then when someone else tries
to replicate this the finding on a new
dataset the high the effect was already
chosen so they're not they're no longer
going to have data that makes that
effect look significant so then now when
they test it it no longer looks as
significant okay so at this point some
of you are thinking we have a we have a
standard way to solve this right this is
a well-known problem in machine learning
when we refer to it as overfitting so we
we have a solution method we use data
splitting right we use different subsets
of data to fit our model to choose our
hypotheses and then some other
validation set to evaluate the model
test its goodness of fit or significance
and so on and this is just an example
where I'm illustrating this on the data
set which has a 240 lymphoma patients
and about 7400 genes and the outcome
variable is a survival time variable so
in this type of a setting you could do a
Cox proportional hazards model but
because there are more predictors than
outcomes we have to do some type of
regularization so we can do a lasso
penalized Cox proportional hazards model
and the GLM net package and r can do
this for us so that's what I've done
here and
the the interesting thing about all this
is it's just a few lines of code to
separate my data into training and test
sets fit a model use cross-validation to
figure out how much to regularize it the
model ends up picking or I should say
the lasso [ __ ] pH model ends up picking
15 genes as being predictive and then if
we use our test data set to give us
inference for those predictors that this
inference over here will actually be
valid it will not suffer from this
selection bias and that's because the
data we use to form these test
statistics was a different subset of
data than the data we use to decide
those or the tests we wanted to do so
this is just an example of data
splitting applied to a sort of
interesting problem and data splitting
is great when we can do it
it's pretty straightforward like that
previous slide showed all basically all
the code that I had to use to do that
entire result and it works often without
making any types of assumptions I might
have to make assumptions for the other
methods I want to use to work data
splitting is is fairly assumption free
and it's gonna work in most settings
almost automatically so you know for
lots of problems data splitting is the
way to go and I certainly am NOT trying
to make sure everyone uses the R package
I'm here to talk about today but in some
settings data splitting won't work or or
it might not be the best way to solve
this selection bias problem so one issue
with data splitting is that it can
affect reproducibility if we're going to
choose random subsets of the data for
training and test splits then someone
can sort of even in even without
intending to try more than one split and
end up going with the result that gives
the most impressive looking conclusions
so they might not even be intending to
do that themselves
they might have just like
the code once and and like they're
changing the way the plot looks or
something when they run it again and you
know likes it if people aren't thinking
very carefully they might not realize
that they can override the intention of
data splitting by trying it multiple
times and if someone else wants to
reproduce your result they might need to
use for example the same random seed to
get the same split of data so there are
some reproducibility issues with it
it also doesn't use all of the available
data so if you have a small sample size
like in this previous example 240 is not
that large of a sample size especially
we've got more than 7,000 predictors so
maybe data splitting isn't the best idea
to solve the problem for this data set
maybe we would prefer to use all 240
observations to fit the model if we
could then we'd like to use the same
data set to do the inference and that's
basically the solution method that I'm
about to discuss will allow us to do
there are also some problems where it's
just not feasible to do data splitting
for example you know there could be some
dependence structure in the data like
time series data our network data where
it just it's harder to figure out how to
split it into independent subsets so
what I'll talk about instead of data
splitting is a conditional probability
approach to dealing with the selection
bias there are a few papers here which
are sort of some of the earliest papers
in this in this area and to motivate
this why we would use a conditional
probability let's think about another
very simple example so let's think about
the example where we just have many
independent effects and we want to apply
a screening rule which is a threshold
enroll we're only going to look at those
effects which are above some cutoff the
ones which are below this cutoff are
kind of you know we don't have enough
time or resources to look at everything
so we're going to first do this
screening so what I'll do is I'll look
at only those effects which are above 1
now once they've made it through my
selection rule I need to determine how I
want to test their significance the red
line here is the standard normal density
and we know we can't use that because
here all of these effects are actually
coming from the null they have a zero
mean and so they don't look the observed
screened effects don't line up with the
standard normal we saw we kind of saw
previous examples of that and this is
just another one but what they do line
up with is the conditional version of
this distribution if we condition on the
fact that they're bigger than one so for
this problem conditioning on them being
bigger than one is the same as
truncating them below at one so this
curve here you can see it lines up
pretty well with the simulated effects
if we use this green curve to decide
what's significant then we would control
type one error again so that's the basic
idea of this conditional approach on a
simple enough example where we can sort
of plot the distributions and understand
what's going on one way of thinking
about this intuitively is that an effect
has to surprise us once to be selected
and then conditional on being selected
it now has to surprise us again to be
considered significant and we're going
to apply this same intuitive idea in
various different settings and the key
thing to remember is that we just have
to take the null distribution of our
test statistic and condition it on the
selection rule so some notation to sort
of define what error probability notion
we're controlling with this a procedure
we call this a selective type 1 error
and what this notation means is it's the
probability of making a type 1 error
because it's computed assuming the null
is true so what's the probability we
reject the null give
that it's true under some model
conditional on that's the model we
selected using the data so we take the
null distribution and then we condition
it on selecting that model so we
construct tests to control this
conditional type one error which we call
selective type one error and several
things that you that there are several
nice properties about this definition
that help motivate it one is that it
reduces to the standard definition of
type 1 error the classical one if the
model is chosen a priori so if your
model selection rule is that you
deterministically we're going to use
model lower case m then this condition
is is deterministic now so it just goes
away so it reduces to the standard
definition if in the case when you
didn't use the data to pick the model
data splitting also controls this type 1
error because the same for the same
reason this conditioning here depends on
a different independent set of data than
the test statistic so the conditional
distribution is the same as the
unconditional distribution in that case
so in both of these cases you can just
delete the conditional part and this
definition reduces to the standard one
so data splitting controls this and it's
the normal definition if we didn't use
the data to pick the model but in
general when we have used the data to
pick the model we have to figure out how
to how the the null distribution for the
test statistic is affected by this
conditioning and we see in many examples
that the way it's affected is that it
becomes truncated to a certain region so
this is a from one of the previously
mentioned papers this is illustrating
the selection region for the lasso so if
we're using the lasso algorithm to pick
variables in our model it turns out that
the event that you pick a certain subset
of variables can be written as a affine
in
quality in your in your outcome variable
why and what that means is that in our n
the outcome space there is a union of
polytopes the shaded regions here what
these shaded regions represent are all
of the outcome variable values which
would have led you to pick the same
model so you're gonna have some observed
value of your outcome variable Y and
your the fact that you've selected this
model means you know that Y is in the
shaded region so now we know we can
condition on selecting this model by
truncating the distribution of Y to the
shaded region so this is the geometry
involved in applying this selective type
1 error idea to model selected by the
lasso it turns out that this this
property here the affine inequality
characterizes a lot of different model
selection algorithms forward stepwise as
well so there are many model selection
algorithms where we can apply this same
basic ideas to conducting the
conditional inference okay so to show
this in action this is from the this is
I'm using functions in the Selective
inference package now and what I'm gonna
do here is I'm gonna generate the data
myself so I know what the true
coefficients are and all that so I've
got 100 observations 200 predictive
variables the first 5 predictor
variables are actually nonzero so it's a
very sparse true model the other 195 of
them are just 0 and what I'm gonna do
here is I'm gonna generate a vector of
outcomes a a matrix of predictor
variables and a vector of predictor
coefficients and then I'll plug this
data synthetic data into the the larger
them-- funk
the law algorithm is just a particular
algorithm that will find lasso solutions
so all this all this is going to do is
use the lasso to pick some predictor
variables out of those 200 variables and
then I use this law inference function
to calculate the conditional inference
conditional on selecting the given
variables and what I see here is that
the the algorithm chooses variables 1
through 5 but it also puts in variable
188 that's pretty impressive because it
found the 5 correct variables out of the
all 200 that's good
and it didn't put in too many other ones
which were incorrect and then I've got a
column of p-values here and I can see
also for the one variable which was a
mistake that shouldn't be included in
the model the p-value for that one is
not significant so I also like that I
and then the other thing that I see is
that for the ones that were selected
they're not all significant and what
this is reflecting is that there's a
reduction in power so we have-we have
less significance these p-values are not
as small but that is necessary because
like I said before these effects have to
surprise us a second time in order to be
declared significant they surprised us
once in order to be included in the
model so if these p-values were all very
small then maybe that testing method
would not control a conditional type 1
error so I I hope this just kind of
illustrates a basic use of this package
and you can see that you can fit lasso
models and then get valid p-values for
the predictor variables in those lasso
models oh and the other thing I should
have mentioned about this is for the
lasso you have to choose how much
regularization to do and what I've done
here is I've used the AIC criteria to
pick the number of variables that's a
little unusual P
often use cross-validation with the
lasso but you can use the AIC criteria
and there are various options in this
package for which criteria to do another
way is to just use a specific value of
lambda the regularization parameter so
here if you're going to use one specific
value of lambda to get one lasso fit
then you can use the function fixed
lasso inference at that value of lambda
and here we have smaller p-values so we
have a less of a loss of power when
we're just looking at one specific value
of lambda rather than choosing it
optimally the AIC chose it optimally
okay and this plot here is just showing
the the lasso coefficients as a function
of lambda so what I've done here by
picking one specific value of lambda is
I'm I'm I'm sort of taking one vertical
slice of this and saying these these
coefficients are my current estimates
there's one other more kind of recent
development to help improve power in
these tests I'm going to actually skip
this though and the last thing I'll
mention is that one of the drawbacks to
this approach has to do with the
reduction in power and a lot of this
reduction in power is due to
conditioning on too much in some sense
we condition on the model the selected
model but in order to compute p-values
we often sometimes have to use these ad
hoc tricks to condition on more things
in order to make the computation simple
and so that extra conditioning can
reduce power and there's a there's a
method to try to to get around that and
improve power by fitting a randomized
version of the lasso so you can think of
this as sort of adding noise to your
response variable in some sense if you
do this then the event that you select a
given model is no longer truncating the
tribution of your original outcome its
truncating the noised version of it but
your original outcome is not fully
truncated and it turns out that that
tends to help with the power of these
tests this this part of the package is
not quite as user-friendly yet hopefully
we're in in a future version of the
package make make the interface with
these functions a little more user
friendly there's one thing that I I kind
of swept under the rug a few slides ago
which is that I told you that I was
fitting the lasso at a fixed value of
lambda but in fact the value of lambda
that I used had a plug in estimate of
the of the variance of the noise and I
got that plug in estimate using
cross-validation basically so it turns
out that if you do this then the
selection event is not really an affine
selection event so there's a little bit
of hand waving that goes on and in doing
something like a plug in estimate here
it's a similar sort of situation to the
situation with Gossett and Fisher where
people were using plug in estimate for
the standard error and Gossett figured
out that you needed to use the
t-distribution instead of the normal
distribution as a result so there's a
similar sort of thing going on here and
there's some good news which is that we
have methods of getting around this one
of them is to use the square root lasso
instead of de la so the square root
lasso does not square the error so
instead of the squared error it's now
just than the regular two norm of the
error and what that does is that means
that the both the the error part and the
penalty part have the same order to them
and so you don't actually need to know
Sigma the variance of the noise to pick
a good value of lambda the
regularization parameter when you do
square root lasso so this is an
advantage of square root lasso and it
means the takeaway is that we can use a
value of lambda which is picked without
looking at your outcome variable Y and
then that means we're now back in the
setting where we really have
a fine selection event and we're not
doing this hand waving plugin thing that
I mentioned previously the bad news is
that this this is not yet in the our
package there is Python code for it
though on our github repository so if
you wanted to use this there if you're
willing to do in path on that that's
that's already done one other approach
to getting around this problem of having
to use the data to pick lambda this is
where I'm going to plug my own specific
research is that the the model selection
event does not have to be an affine
event we can also deal with quadratic
selection events and it turns out that
using cross-validation to pick a given
lasso model is a quadratic selection
event so that's the good news and the
bad news is that tends to have very low
power because cross-validation uses the
data very exhaustively so when we
condition on using cross-validation we
end up conditioning away a lot of power
okay so just to wrap up with some
conclusions there are some other
complimentary our approaches with our
packages as well so they're there there
are Bayesian approaches to dealing with
this question of trying to use lasso to
get a sparse model but also give
inference there are a number of
approaches that are based on D biasing
your original estimate you use your
penalized regression technique like
lasso to get a biased estimate of beta
and then you do something to D by as'
that and you apply asymptotic normality
so there are a number of approaches that
approaches that apply that sort of
technique and then there's an approach
called Posey or for post selection
inference which which gives a
simultaneous infants guarantee over all
possible sub models which is a very
robust type of guarantee it's very
strong but that means this is also a
fairly conservative and computationally
intensive procedure so this procedure I
don't think they yet I don't think they
have code yet that can get beyond for
example like 20 predictor variables
because you have to do a best subset
search to apply this so
if you're interested in goodness-of-fit
tests there's also the RP test package
by Rajan Shah and Peter Billman which
can do goodness-of-fit tests and high
dimensional regression and I have some
forthcoming research where we might end
up getting giving a similar
functionality to the selective inference
package so just to just to give the
high-level takeaway messages once more
using the data to decide which
inferences to conduct results in
selection bias and we have various names
for this problem depending on what
community we come from
you can either over fit or you can be
anti conservative or conservative
depending on what type of test you're
doing if you can't apply data splitting
for some reason or you don't want to you
have alternatives and the Selective
inference conditional approach is one
the this package is on cran you can find
it you can download and start fitting
the lasso and getting p-values and then
there's these other packages that you
could try as well so that's
[Applause]
see the selection at all but there's
definitely slashing art month as well as
possibly seduced by fellow you know see
this I'm gonna see another Pisces what
is her very important
don't be easier no a great great
question by the way it's an area of
active research that various people have
different sorts of questions and
approaches one one one thing to think
about is that often when you're doing
causal inference it means that you have
one particular variable your treatment
which you know you're going to do the
entrance for so you're not actually
worried about a selection bias on
choosing to test the treatment itself
but what you might want to do if you're
in a high dimensional regression setting
is choose which things to control for
and there are there are approaches
that's the MM L problem and but but one
aspect of that is since you're not
choosing what the target is you don't
have to worry about the selection bias
of the test at the target you have sort
of different things to worry about than
exactly what the topic of this problem
was but like the whole point of double
ml is trying to address what problems
arise in that particular setting and
there are also versions of the double ml
problem which are a little which are
more directly connected where you might
for example not know which interactions
of the treatment variable with other
effects that you want to test so you
could think about testing for
heterogeneity by interacting your
treatment variable with some subset
group variables and use the data to pick
which of those you actually want to to
report inference for and then you could
be in this exactly this sort of setting
and you might want to use these sorts of
tools to to do that but yeah it's just
stepping back from those it's a good
question where it's something I've
thought about but I don't have any
ongoing work on but there are a number
of people who do
yeah so you can make data splitting more
efficient with cross-validation for
example by switching which of the two
subsets you use for selection and
inference an issue you have to deal with
in is stability because the model
selection algorithm can be unstable and
you could deal with the you get
different models selected on the
different subsets so then you've got to
come up with you've got to address the
fact that you're no longer going to be
interested in one specific regression
model with one set of predict one
particular subset of predictors that
were chosen you might have different
subsets of predictors chosen across the
different folds or something like that
and so you've now got to start dealing
with model and stability and think about
things like model averaging and so on
and actually that that is the focus of
one of the alternative methods here
called stability selection so stability
selection is in the title of a paper
about this and the authors of that paper
have this package but some other people
also implemented a package doing this
the same thing so these these two
packages here will do something like
that so they'll do cross validation they
will they'll actually use that model
instability to to aggregate models
together and use the sort of like how
often a predictor variable is included
in a given model as the notion of
stability and the stable set and yeah so
that that's it that's a good point and
it's very closely related to one of
these complementary approaches
[Music]